foreign
[Music]
everyone my name is Dr Miller and the
SCP we're going to be looking at today
is
scp-3348 object class safe
special containment procedures
scp-3348 is to be kept in a safe secured
via a combination lock at least five
characters in length which itself is to
be contained within a safe class
containment chamber
in order to prevent the contents of
scp-3348 from being spoken outside of
testing the anti-chamber connecting the
containment chamber to the remainder of
the facility is to be equipped with a
mechanism capable of dispensing class a
targeted amnestics whenever Personnel
without level 3 3348 clearance or higher
exit the chamber the mechanism is to be
activated in order to erase their
memories of said contents
description
scp-3348 is a black leather-bound
Journal written in a white field on the
front cover is the title The compiled
vocabulary of the cage nathonian
language my mandrid matzer
the first several pages of the journal
contain handwritten entries listing
words in a previously unknown language
presumably Cajun ethonian along with
their translations these words are
characterized by their extreme length no
entry has been observed to be any less
than six syllables long in addition
Foundation linguists are currently
unable to find consistent traits between
each instance as if their structures are
completely random
the remaining pages are blank but an
extra piece of loose paper was found in
the back of the journal at the time of
recovery the addendum 3348 O2
scp-3348's anomalous properties manifest
when an individual henceforth referred
to as the subject speaks one of the
words contained within it as soon as the
word is completely spoken all instances
of the entity are concept that is
associated with will become negatively
affected in some way within a 30 meter
radius of the subject this effect
manifests in one of three General ways
depending upon the chosen words part of
speech
nouns the affected entities will be
altered in such a way that they will no
longer be able to perform their intended
function and or attempting to use them
will cause harm to the user
verbs for 30 seconds after the subject
speaks the word any one or anything
attempting to perform their respective
action will invariably fail usually
hurting themselves or others in the
process
adjectives entities exhibiting the
respective trait will lose it
addendum
3348-01 test log
the following is a list of the initial
tests conducted with entries found
within scp-3348
entry tested cerix
part of speech noun translation knife
procedure a knife and length of rope are
placed on a table the subject is asked
to speak the word then attempt to cut
the rope with the knife
results the edge of the knife briefly
Heats to degrees Celsius before cooling
down now visibly dull subject attempts
to make a cut in the Rope for
approximately 5 minutes before the knife
suddenly snaps in half
entry tested guzzla edit part of speech
verb translation to walk
procedure
d-50339 subject B is asked to attempt to
walk from one end of the testing chamber
to another after the word is spoken
result subject B begins to walk forward
after a couple of steps his legs buckle
and he falls to the ground several more
attempts are made each resulting in the
same outcome until the end of the 32nd
period
and retested keep e War yak part of
speech verb translation to fall
procedure after the word is spoken
subject is asked to lift a bowling ball
off of the table and drop it at their
feet results the bowling ball does not
fall suspending itself in the air where
it was released after the 32nd time
period it falls to the ground at
terminal velocity subject sustains minor
injuries
entry-tested
we cook part of speech adjective
translation red procedure a red apple is
placed on a table and observed after the
word is spoken
results the skin of the Apple turns from
red to a visual phenomena that is
described by those present as
Indescribable and incomprehensible
subject and observing personnels suffer
from major headaches for the following
hours
entry test it at jerichon
part of speech adjective translation
large
procedure a standard brand refrigerator
is placed next to a sculpture of a fork
made to be roughly the same size both
are observed after the word is spoken
result the sculpture is shrunk into the
size of a regular Fork but the
refrigerator remains unaffected
researchers note
this test reveals an interesting
property of scp-3348 although the fridge
in the fork were about the same size
only the fork was considered large this
seems to suggest some level of sentience
as the perception of the subject seems
to make a difference in the outcome we
will test on more perception-based
entries to confirm this hypothesis
lead researcher Dr Hampton
entry tested
part of speech noun
translation love procedure
d03934 and
d-14045 subjects B and C who are known
to be romantically involved with each
other are placed together in the testing
chamber and observed after the word is
spoken results subject B and subject C
look at each other with apparent looks
of disgust and hatred moving away from
each other and repeatedly requesting
they be removed from the testing chamber
as soon as possible
entry tested
s mid-af
part of speech adjective translation
hostile
procedure subject a security officer is
to say the word then interact with
d99328 subject B note that subject B has
on multiple occasions verbally and
physically assaulted subject a and has
openly expressed his negative regards
towards him result subject B enters room
in which subject a is waiting and
Exhibits a positive reaction to him
greeting him warmly and offering a
handshake subject a is prompted by
researchers to refuse and provoke the
subject B but subject B's disposition
sees no apparent change since this
experiment subject B has been
uncharacteristically Cooperative with
staff
entry tested it's Guapo part of speech
verb translation improve procedure
researcher doctor subject B and Junior
researcher Dr
subject C who is a tomato allergy are
asked to apply generous servings of
ketchup to hamburgers placed in front of
them simultaneously after the word is
spoken
results subject B effortlessly performs
the task but subject C expresses
overwhelming difficulty when attempting
to tip the ketchup bottle to the
appropriate angle when subject B is
prompted to attempt to assist he reports
that he cannot move it until subject C
removes her hands from the bottle
entry tested
part of speech noun translation property
procedure three identical staplers items
one through three are placed on a table
in front of the subject and observed
after the word is spoken item one was
bought by the subject item 2 was bought
by an associate and given to the subject
and item three was brought in
specifically for this test results these
spring mechanisms of items 1 and 2
suddenly snap but item 3 remains intact
and fully functional
notice from lead researcher Dr Hampton
upon review of the collected data from
the above tests it is of my professional
opinion that further testing by our team
will fail to yield any additional
meaningful information however if you
are a researcher needing to use scp-3348
for your own experiments please have a
project lead contact me so that
Arrangements may be made
addendum
3348-02 recovery
scp-3348 was recovered and contained on
20 shortly after several Hume sensors
detected a sudden and brief drop 0.5
kilometers away from the front entrance
of Psych where it is currently being
held upon recovery a handwritten note
was found in the back of the journal on
a separate piece of paper the contents
of the node are as follows
to whomever finds it
I need you to keep my work safe
as I write this there are several very
angry individuals coming to destroy what
I've done
to think my own colleagues my former
friends supposedly dedicated to the
preservation of Truth and knowledge
coming to me and all of a sudden telling
me that recording it is wrong when I
discovered the Cajun ethonian language
it was nearly lost to history I thought
I was the first
turns out I wasn't
and they tried to bury history on
purpose
some ancient war or something of the
sword I'm not sure
but they nearly destroyed all records of
the Cajun ethonians on purpose
nearly
they said what I was doing was forbidden
so here I am now
writing to you in a dark corner of the
library
hoping that this way leads to where I
think it does no safer place in the
universe than one of the jealous cells
right
please I know that your people are as
dedicated to the protection of knowledge
as I am or maybe by now
was
hopefully this Arrangement won't be
permanent if I get out of this alive
I'll be coming for my book
I fully intend to finish what I started
from one scholar to another
moza
given the content of the note as well as
the circumstances of
scp-3348's recovery it is to be assumed
that the individual known as Mandarin
monster somehow obtained knowledge of
the location or at least the approximate
location of sight and has a means to
reach it an investigation to find the
possible mode of information leakage is
currently underway hand site security
has been updated accordingly
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James sama
braided Peach
that loser
heroin sick
Richard broadhurst
fire of prime
Indy versus the world
rubbish bin 69
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you